Nancy Pelosi talks race Paul Krugman
talks fascism and President Trump talks
in afta so a lot of talking I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show I
[Music]
have a lot to get to today I have a
crazy story out of Brown University that
really is indicative of where the left
is intellectually and it is not a good
place but first I want to talk to you
about your wireless provider the big in
big wireless provider stands for a lot
of things big contracts big bills big
fees AT&T has a new 800 million dollar
administrative fee increase what big
Wireless doesn't actually want you to
know is that there's a way to cut your
wireless bill all the way down to 15
bucks a month which is where mint mobile
comes in they're the game-changing
company that's taken everything wrong
with big Wireless and they've made it
right you can save probably a thousand
dollars a year with mint mobile without
sacrificing quality of service they work
with other companies to ensure that your
coverage is the best there is it's just
terrific mint mobile makes it really
easy to cut your wireless bill down in
just fifteen bucks a month use your own
phone with any mint mobile plan you can
keep your old number along with all your
existing contacts you can choose between
2 5 or 10 gigabyte 4G LTE plans no more
paying for unlimited data that you're
never going to use every plan comes with
unlimited text and talk and if you're
not 100% satisfied mint mobile has you
covered with their 7 day money-back
guarantee they save you money by cutting
out the middleman and also they're not
gonna sell you data packages you're
never going to use ditch your old
wireless bill start saving with mint
mobile to get your new mint Wireless
plan for just 15 bucks a month plus free
shipping on your mint Mobile SIM card go
to mint mobile comm slash Ben that's mi
n t-mobile comm slash Ben mint mobile
comm / Ben cut your wireless bill down
to 15 bucks a month get free shipping on
that SIM card at mint mobile comm slash
menus at /bin to let them know that we
sent you okay so well the media keep
proclaiming that Donald Trump is the
scariest person who ever was President
Trump continues to bash the the
mainstream media continues to suggest
that they are indeed fake news he
continued that this morning when he woke
up at 5:30 in the morning and decided to
rewatch lou dobbs yes that's actually
what happened he well quit 5:30 in the
morning and he TiVo's a lot of the shows
on Fox News and Fox Business and he
decided to watch Lou Dobbs a show Lou
Dobbs is talking about the search
results over in Google and president
Trump decided to tweet this out this is
14 do it out Google search results put
Trump news shows only the viewing
reporting of fake new media in other
words they have it rigged for me and
others so that almost all stories and
news is bad fake CNN is prominent
Republican conservative and fair media
is shut out illegal 96% of results on
Trump news are from national left-wing
media very dangerous Google and others
are suppressing voices of conservatives
and hiding information and news that is
good they're controlling what we can and
cannot see this is a very serious
situation will be addressed well I don't
think the president actually Google's
things hey he apparently doesn't use a
computer really so the where he got this
information is that Lou Dobbs was
talking about search results when it
comes to Google is and it's true that
the Google News bias in favor of large
media organizations is pretty severe and
that does have an actual impact on the
kind of news that people consume and it
does mean that they actually consume a
fair bit of misinformation that is put
out by the mainstream media now it's
important to remember that when
President Trump says things like fake
news and means just any news he doesn't
like he was not the originator of the
phrase fake news the originator of the
phrase Fignon Trump says that he made it
up he didn't make it up it was made up
by the left the left suggested that
Hillary Clinton had lost the election if
you recall due to fake news they're a
bunch of false stories put out on
Facebook people believe those false
stories and then they voted for Donald
Trump instead of Hillary Clinton
president Trump said the actual fake
news are the members of the mainstream
media and unfortunately members of the
mainstream media seem intent on proving
his point almost every day the latest
example comes courtesy of CNN so
President Trump has focused on CNN
incessantly and there's a reason for
that here's the latest example CNN
absolutely botched a story claiming the
president from knew in advance about the
June 2016 Trump Tower meeting between
members of the Trump campaign and a
Russian back lawyer supposedly offering
dirt on Hillary Clinton you know there's
been a lot of focus on this particular
meeting obviously because in the run-up
to the meeting Donald Trump jr. was
emailing with an associate of his from
Russia who is basically saying that the
Russian government wants to supply the
Trump campaign with dirt on Hillary so
why don't you meet with this lawyer and
Trump jr. was like sounds great and then
they had the meeting well one of the big
questions has been did Trump know in
advance about the meeting
well CNN reported July 26th 2018
claiming that Trump did know in advance
about the meaning well it turns out the
person who supplied that information was
lanny davis who's the clinton associated
where for michael cohen
who at the time was attempting to show
the muller investigation that michael
cohen had something valuable to offer
CNN says it stands by the story but
Davis told The Washington Post this week
quote I should have been more clear
including with you that I could not
independently confirm what happened I
regret my error Davis also told the
Anderson Cooper of CNN I think the
reporting of the story got mixed up in
the course of a criminal investigation
we were not the source of the story the
CNN story originally said Davis offered
no comment it turns out that on
background he had actually provided
virtually all of the story CNN said
quote we stand by our story we are
confident in our reporting of it that
story rocketed around the media was
echoed by NBC News and The Washington
Post according to BuzzFeed news Davis
was the confirming source for all of
that those admissions follow another
admission from Lanny Davis Michael
Cohen's lawyer regarding a claim that
President Trump knew beforehand about
the hacking of Democratic emails by the
Russians now Davis says quote I am not
sure there's a possibility that is the
case but I am not sure so the source for
half of the media's news regarding
Russian collusion and Trump Tower and
all the rest of it is Lanny Davis the
lawyer for Michael Cohen who has now
gone on record admitting that he doesn't
know what the hell he's talking about
CNN stands by the story anyway according
to BuzzFeed News quote the network in
effect doesn't appear to believe it made
a mistake the story was some inside CNN
argue carefully warded to hedge against
those in the Cohen camp changing their
tune in other words the story reports
claim that Cohen had said he was willing
to make not the underlying truth of
those claims in other words CNN says
listen we didn't report that Cohen knew
that Trump had known about the Trump
Tower meeting in advance no the CNN
story reported that Cohen was willing to
tell prosecutors that he might have
known about that stuff so we had
carefully caveated this right the
decision from CNN to continue to stand
by the story suggests it believes the
strength of its other sources outweighs
any waffling from Davis according to
BuzzFeed or that the network believes
Davis was telling the truth then and not
now but Davis's new statement that he
was the source for a story he now
refutes raise questions about what
action if any the network might take we
should address Lenny Davis's comments in
our reporting and be more transparent
with our readers about our report in one
CNN staffer told BuzzFeed news now I
have some person
experience with stories like this so I
remember back in 2013 Chuck Hagel was
nominated for Secretary of Defense by
the Obama administration Chuck Hagel was
in my opinion radically anti-israel he
was a he was a in isolationist on
foreign policy and there was a big push
from the right to stop Chuck Hagel's
nomination well I was supplied
information by top sources in the Senate
that that Chuck Hagel had spoken to some
group called Friends of Hamas was just a
rumor and we reported it on Breitbart
news as a rumor the actual title of the
piece said we called up the White House
the White House basically hung up on us
and the the title of piece was something
like White House spokesperson hangs up
about based on rumors of friends of
hamas something like that it was pretty
clear in the piece that it was a rumor
now that was correctly reported rumor
because it turns out that the rumor was
not true but should we have reported it
in the first place the answer is no and
I've said this multiple times since it
was a mistake not to retract the story
it was a mistake to report the story in
the first place CNN basically did the
same thing here but they're not backing
off the story right the same mainstream
media that suggested that story was bad
and was largely right is now suggesting
that this story by CNN is kind of okay
and then President Trump complaining
about fake news is labeled crazy you
have folks in the media claiming that
the news media are the reliable sources
in all of this it's hard to give a lot
of credibility to news sources that
holds a double standard when it comes to
people on the right they would never
hold for people on the left and the
levels to which the media will go in
order to disparage and slander the Trump
administration are pretty astonishing
it's mostly astonishing because if they
would just be accurate about the Trump
administration it's not like they would
have nothing to report but the opinions
of the left are so out of the realm of
normalcy
that it's it's almost impossible to
defend take for example this column from
Jill philipovich this isn't this is not
an objective news piece this is a column
but Joe philipovich is a feminist author
and she's the the author of a book
called the H spot the feminist pursuit
of happiness which is that the book is
completely blank there is no feminist
pursuit of happiness
it's just like Michael Moses book so Joe
philipovich writes a piece called stormy
Daniels feminist hero this is how far
the left is willing to go stormy Daniels
a porn star who spends her entire career
legitimately catering to the worst in
men is now a is now a feminist here
for having sex with a married man once
in order to get on the apprentice and
then taking money to shut up about it
and then reneging on the taking of the
money to shut up about it to make a big
deal about it she's a feminist here
here's Jill philipovich quote let's take
a moment for stormy Daniels on Tuesday
Michael Kohn pled guilty to breaking
campaign finance laws charges stemming
from payments he made to two women one
of them miss Daniels with whom is with
whom Donald Trump is said to have had an
affair mr. Cohen a former lawyer for mr.
Trump says he made the payments at the
direction of the president in an effort
to influence the 2016 election it's an
extraordinary admission and an
extraordinary political moment not just
because of what it means for mr. Trump
it marks an unanticipated feminist
turning point miss Daniels is an adult
film star and like the president an
unapologetic self-promoter hers is not a
female archetype that has historically
garnered much respect trust or sympathy
well yeah because she legitimately gets
paid to have sex on film so that other
men can masturbate to it that is
legitimately her career so yeah I
wouldn't go with feminist archetype
there yet here she is an imperfect
entirely self possessed woman telling
her story with clarity and without shame
and here we are actually listening to
her hey let's be clear the only reason
anybody's listening to her is because
one period interest and - she's saying
crap about a president at the left aids
this is why there's so much power in the
fact that miss Daniels does not believe
her job or her involvement with mr.
Trump or the payoff is her shame to
carry she wants him held accountable and
the justice system is actually stepping
in she's refusing to slink away
despite being paid to do exactly that in
a pattern we've seen too many times from
influential men seeking to maintain
their dominance and avoid
responsibilities
did I miss something here I thought
stormy Daniels was paid to voluntarily
go away and signed a contract to that
effect was she forced into anything here
I missed that part so just to be clear
when you violate a contract that's good
and feminist so long as it hurts Donald
Trump Jill filipova traits miss Daniels
is a sex worker making fun of a kind of
bad woman scorned for her work who's
often not believed when she incites a
powerful man well her work is garbage
and when she quote in Deitz a powerful
man we sort of have to decide whether or
not she is credible her credibility is
not really called into question by the
fact that she's a porn star she's not
even claiming she was sexually assaulted
her harassed she's claiming
that she had sex with a guy once and
then won't shut up about it before an
election right that's that's
legitimately her entire claim but this
makes her a feminist hero in a second we
will talk about the feminist heroism of
a woman who does girl-on-girl scenes for
pay but first let's talk about life
insurance oh if all of this makes you
want to kill yourself then probably you
should get some life insurance because
well life interesting gonna cover
suicide but in any case a better
transition would probably be you need
life insurance because if you die your
family's gonna want money right I mean
let's be real about this we're all gonna
plotz and when we do it would be a
mistake for you not to have life
insurance life insurance is really
important it's also really confusing
which is why four out of ten people
don't have it maybe you're one of those
folks maybe even holding off because
you're procrastinating but now is the
time to get life insurance because the
rates are the lowest they have been in
twenty years the best time to buy is now
the best place to buy is policy genius
calm policy genius is the easy way to
compare life insurance online in just
five minutes you can compare quotes from
the top insurers to find the best policy
for you and when you compare quotes you
save money it is indeed that simple
policy genius has helped over 4 million
people shop for insurance placed over 20
billion dollars in coverage they don't
just make life insurance easy they also
compared disability insurance and
renter's insurance and health insurance
if you care about it they can cover it
so if you've been putting off getting
life insurance there's no reason to put
it off any longer
go to policy genius com get quotes
applying minutes it's that easy rates
are the lowest in 20 years policy genius
calm the easy way to compare and buy
life insurance go check out policy
genius right now so as Jill philipovich
says the left is celebrating stormy
Daniels as a hero and the reason that I
cite this is because well the opinion
pages in the New York Times
objective news pages are separate the
reality is that they're not quite all
that separate ok the same media
sensibility that informs an editorial
page that thinks Jill philipovich has
relevant things to say about Stormies
annuals being a feminist hero there are
the same folks who are pushing bad news
over at CNN the the hard distinction
between opinion and journalism doesn't
really exist ok it's why we over at the
daily water admit what our biases are
but the objective news media at places
like Siena and will not admit that bias
instead they claim their objective truth
tellers when in reality most of them
feel feel like Jo foo Phillip Povich
does anyway Philip Povich continues she
says miss Daniels his lack of shame
about her line of work has led to a
right-wing escalation with conservative
media outlets hounding her as a
prostitute once they realize
Schumi pour and start with the shrug
well I mean no people were calling her
kind of a prostitute because she was
kind of a prostitute I mean just like
having sex on film for pay is not
markedly better than having sex not on
film for pay Rudy Guiliani one of mr.
Trump's lawyers said in June although he
respects to all human beings miss
Daniels is apparently one exception he
said I don't respect a porn star the way
I respect a career woman or a woman of
substance or a woman who has great
respect for herself as a woman and as a
person he said and isn't going to sell
her body for sexual exploitation so
stormy you want to bring a case let me
cross-examine you
the threat is that mr. Giuliani would do
to miss Daniels what lawyers have done
for centuries to imperfect women and in
particular rape victims okay how is a
feminist equating a woman who has sex
for money on film for the pleasure of
men with a rape victim how is that even
a possibility you under the most anti
feminist thing that I've heard today it
is this okay it's not anything that Rudy
Giuliani said is something I'm saying
right now the most anti feminists thing
you can say is that stormy Daniels is
akin to a rape victim in any way she's
not a raped that tamesha's woman who
voluntarily has sex for money again none
of this is to let President Trump off
the hook for stooping women who have sex
for money which she does apparently on a
fairly regular basis but the left
attempts to paint everyone who is anti
Trump as some sort of great hero in the
struggle I don't think it's gonna
renounce their benefit in the long run
Phillip Povich says mr. Giuliani
contrasted miss Daniels with three
beautiful women classy women women of
great substance who mr. Trump has
married perfectly encapsulating the
profoundly misogynist virgin
dichotomy imposed on women where we can
only be perfectly good or entirely bad
well no women can be flawed but if you
choose to do what stormy Daniels does
that comes along with some character
consequences it's pretty insane that
this article was considered brilliant
enough to make the pages of the New York
Times but this is where we are this is
this is where we are so this is this is
just great stuff stormy Daniels heroin
that's not the only element of stupidity
in the pages of New York Times The New
York Times also features today a piece
by Paul Krugman who is one of the one of
the appointed idiots over at the New
York Times Krugman knows something about
international currency he knows nothing
about virtually anything else she has a
piece today in the New York Times
talking about how Donald Trump is
ushering in the era of fascism he says
why it can happen here we are very close
to becoming another poll
or Hungary he says soon after the fall
of the Berlin Wall a friend of mine an
expert on international relations made a
joke
now that Eastern Europe is free from the
alien ideology of communism it can
return to its true historical path
fascism even at the time his quip had a
real edge as of 2018 it hardly seems
like a joke at all when Freedom House
calls a liberalism is on the rise across
Eastern Europe this includes Poland and
Hungary both still members of the EU in
which democracy as we normally
understand it is already dead in both
countries the ruling party's law
injustice in Poland Fidesz and Hungary
have established regimes that maintain
the forms of popular elections but have
destroyed the Independence of the
judiciary suppress freedom of the press
institutionalized large-scale corruption
and effectively dually legitimize
dissent the result seems likely to be
one-party rule for the foreseeable
future this is correct by the way the
situation in Hungary and Poland is not a
good one
a lot of the the moves toward liberalism
in the aftermath of the Communist
collapse has been replaced by a move
toward one-party rule in quasi fascist
mode Jaime Kerchak has a great book on
this called the end of Europe that have
recommended on the show before and he
talks specifically about the situations
in places like Poland and Hungary but
here's where Krugman goes wrong since it
could all too easily happen here there's
a time not long ago when people used to
say our democratic norms our proud
history of freedom would protect us from
such a slide into tyranny in fact some
people still say that believing such a
thing today requires willful blindness
the fact is that the Republican Party is
ready even eager to become an American
version of law and justice or Fidesz
exploiting its current political power
to lock in permanent rule hey this
column is gonna look really stupid when
and if the Democrats win back the house
in 2018 the Senate in 2020 and the
presidency in 2020 this idea that
one-party rule is on the horizon here
that that's the next thing that's
happening is just utterly baseless there
is no evidence for it whatsoever and
Krugman tries to cite a few a few
situations in which Republicans have
have moved to strip particular public
officials of of power for example North
Carolina where after a Democrat won the
governorship Republicans passed
legislation stripping the governor's
office of power okay that's why they saw
the legislature in North Carolina but in
any case he suggests that what's
happened is that the Republicans have
moved toward fascism they've moved
toward the Hungary Poland model now I
will acknowledge that the populism of
Donald Trump is a lot more akin to
right-wing nationalist parties in Europe
it is two traditional republican
principles in many ways in terms of his
actual governance however his actual
governance has been small government
conservatism except when it comes to a
lot of spending proposals so Trump talks
like a right-wing European nationalist
there's no question about that when it
comes to policy that's not quite the
same thing we have a system of checks
and balances in the United States that
directly cuts against this sort of
assumption of power also Krugman goes
out of his way to ignore a lot of the
conditions that led to the rise of those
right-wing parties in Europe
perchik talks about in that book end of
Europe why it is that all these
right-wing parties have risen and there
are a couple of reasons one of those
reasons is the politically correct
attempt to rewrite history in certain
ways that led to a severe backlash in a
lot of these countries and the second is
a forcible attempt to impose bars on
discussion about things like immigration
so one of the reasons that you've seen
for example the the Swedish Democrats
which is of a more right-wing party in
Sweden starts to gain all sorts of power
is because there is a forcible attempt
in Sweden to quash any serious
discussion about the influx of
immigrants from the Middle East into
Sweden that led to a serious backlash
and small fringe parties suddenly
gaining a lot of prominence you've seen
that happen across Europe in other words
left-wing attempt to stifle discussion
has actually led to a move toward a more
authoritarian form of government in in
various areas of Europe and yet that's
exactly what the Left seeks to do on a
routine basis here in the United States
Krugman says that all the principles of
the of the Republican Party are gone and
it's just because they lost their
principles he says why is America the
birthplace of democracy so close to
following the lead of other countries
that have recently destroyed it don't
tell me about economic anxiety that's
not what happened in Poland which grew
steadily through the financial crisis in
its aftermath and it's not what happened
here in 2016
study after study has found that racial
resentment not economic distress drove
Trump voters know what those studies
actually found is that resentment at a
left that castigated people on the right
as cultural Outsiders is what drove
Trump to victory okay this idea that it
was purely issues of race is nonsense
what it really was was cultural anxiety
about a left that was championing the
idea that America was changing for the
better because all of the people in the
middle of the country were being
marginalized that white blue-collar
workers in Ohio were being marginalized
and the press was cheering that on as a
grand victory of the leftist vision that
has driven a lot of people into the arms
of a sort of toxic populism that is that
is quite bad in rhetoric but the United
States is a lot more robust and its
defenses against those sort of things
than Europe is number one and number two
the Left refuses to acknowledge its own
culpability in helping to bring about
the rise of exactly that sort of
populism which by the way is mirrored by
a populism on the left from people like
Bernie Sanders I'll give you an example
of this sort of political correctness
that is taking over to the left this is
an amazing example so over at Brown
University there was a a study okay
there's a there's a new story about a
study rather and that study focused in
on what we'll talk about sorry hold on
we'll talk about the study in just one
second first we need to talk about you
upgrading your business okay so if you
need upgrade your business you need
better employees let's be real about
this the people you have working for you
they're mediocre at best you need to get
some new people in there new blood fresh
blood zip recruiter is for you zip
recruiter sends your job to over 100 of
the web's leading job boards they don't
stop there with their powerful matching
technology zip recruiter scans thousands
of resumes to find people with the right
experience and invite them to apply to
your job as applications come in zip
recruiter analyzes everyone in a
spotlight the top candidates you never
miss a great match zip recruiter is so
effective that 80% of employers who post
on zip recruiter get a quality candidate
through the site within the first day
with results like that it is no wonder
the zip recruiter is the highest rated
hiring site in the United States and
right now my listeners can try zip
recruiter for free at this exclusive web
address zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire that zip recruiter com slash daily
Wire Dai ly w ir e zip recruiter comm
slash daily why we used it here at the
daily wire offices it's great zip
recruiter is indeed the smartest way to
hire and again you can try it out for
free at zip recruiter comm slash daily
wire okay so I'm arguing here that
political correctness has helped drive a
populist backlash that is not good for
the country I don't think the populist
backlash is great for the country but I
think the political correctness is even
worse for the country
and so what we've seen is the toxicity
in politics that is led by an attempt to
quash debate not just about terrible
horrible no good very bad ideas but
about mainstream ideas I'm talking about
mainstream scientific investigation is
being forcibly quashed by the forces of
political correctness on the Left
today's example is particularly insane
comes courtesy of Brown University so
Brown University has now pulled down a
news story on a study conducted by one
of its own researchers the study focused
on what it described as rapid onset
gender dysphoria hey gender dysphoria
gender identity disorder transgenderism
that was not present in early youth
cases wasn't a kid who was three and
said I'm a little boy when it was a
little girl instead it was gender
dysphoria that manifested within days or
weeks and teens and young adults in
other words it's become trendy in some
areas of the world for people to declare
themselves transgender and you've seen
this in statistics the number of people
in Britain who have reported themselves
to basically Institute's that helped the
old transgenderism has doubled in the
course of one year don't tell me that
evolution radically shifted in the
course of one year or that there were
this many people who are transgender who
just realized it in the last year that
they'd felt this way since they were
three but now that they watched it on TV
they finally finally realized that this
was happening as I say when it comes to
human behavior a large component of
human behavior is indeed biological and
a huge component of human behavior is
biological responses to environment
environment does matter when it comes to
all sorts of behavior it's so funny the
left will acknowledge this when it comes
to things like IQ and that IQ is indeed
responsive to a certain extent to
environment they'll deny that I can't
even exist with regard to biology which
is bizarre or at least they'll make the
case that biological studies with regard
to IQ should not be done because we
can't look at the biology of IQ but we
certainly should pretend that all sexual
behavior is neatly biological and
therefore if you have a drive toward a
sexual behavior this means that you were
born this way right this is the K it is
the Lady Gaga case about biology the
reality of the the the reality is that
human behavior is quite malleable
particularly in the sexual arena and one
of the things that has happened with
regard to transgenderism is as it
becomes more prominence in the media
there are more and more people who are
being confused there are more and more
people who believe that because they
feel like outsiders this must mean that
they actually are outsiders in their own
body and that's essentially what this
study was positing what the the study
author is a woman named Lisa Lippmann I
assume that she's on the left because
she works at Brown I can't imagine that
she's not she's an assistant professor
of the practice of behavioral and social
sciences at Browns School of Public
Health and she stated quote this kind of
descriptive study is important because
it defines a group and raises questions
for more research one of the main
conclusions is that more research needs
to be done
you can tell by the way that she doesn't
like the conclusions of her own study
when she keeps saying more research
needs to be done
she's descriptive studies aren't
randomized control trials
you can't tell cause and effect you
can't tell prevalence it's gonna take
more studies to bring in more
information but this is a start so what
exactly was the study here's what the
study found Lippmann talked to 250
parents of children who suffered from
rapid onset gender dysphoria according
to science daily among the noteworthy
patterns Lippmann found in the survey
data 21% of parents reported their child
had one or more friends become
transgender identified at around the
same time 20% reported an increase in
their child's social media use around
the same time as experiencing gender
dysphoria symptoms 45% reported both so
in other words a large large minority of
parents who were surveyed about kids who
you know when they're 13 suddenly
realized that they are a quote unquote
of the opposite gender a huge percentage
of those kids were being influenced by
their peers a huge percentage of them
were having peers who decided they were
transgender and now okay my best friend
is transgender so maybe that means I'm
transgender and a huge percentage of
them are on social media more revelling
presumably in transgender media coverage
the pattern of clusters of teens in
friend groups becoming transgender
identified the group dynamics of these
friend groups and the types of advice
viewed online led Littman to the
hypothesis that friends and online
sources could spread certain beliefs
which is common sense and which is
something that folks on the right have
been saying that when you have a society
that pushes certain messages about
sexuality it actually has an impact on
how people behave sexually which we have
known forever okay it's true with regard
to porn habits it is true with regard to
homosexuality it is true with regard to
transgenderism it is true with regard to
every sort of type of sexual
experimentation the more exposure a
certain practice gets in the media the
more people are going to try it out and
that's not saying there's not a
biological component to transgenderism
perhaps there is I assume that there
probably is particularly in young kids
it's not even assuming there's not a
biological component too it's certainly
not assuming there's not a biological
component to homosexuality particularly
when it comes to you twin studies it
shows there is a biological component
although the idea that it's completely
biological is belied by the fact that
even in twin studies about 50% of twins
are our disparate meaning if you have
genetically identical twins only about
50% of
are both gay right if one's gay the
other one half the time is straight
which would suggest it's not completely
biological since they have the same DNA
examples so what are these beliefs that
are being promulgated by media examples
include the belief then nonspecific
symptoms such as feeling uncomfortable
in their own skins or feeling like they
don't fit in which could be part of
normal puberty or associated with trauma
should be perceived as gender dysphoria
in other words the media and friends
constantly saying you feel uncomfortable
in your own skin or you are god forbid
rape something terrible happen to you
and now you feel uncomfortable sexually
maybe it's because you're actually a
member of the opposite gender and what
other beliefs the belief that the only
path to happiness is transition which is
something that the media push non-stop a
non-stop the media push this idea that
if you are uncomfortable in your own
skin the only possible solution is
hormone treatments and to mutilate your
genitals the belief that anyone who
disagrees with the teen is transphobic
and should be cut out of their life and
this is another one of the areas that if
you are a if you are a teen and you go
to your parents and you say mom I'm
actually a boy and you're a girl and
your parents say no sweetheart you know
I know that you're having a tough time
right now let's go talk to a
psychologist that this means your
parents is transphobic and hates you and
is something that's being pushed also
this what the study says of the parents
who provided information about their
child's friendship group about a third
respondent and more than half of the
kids in the friendship group became
transgender identified more than half
the kids in a particular transgender
group became transgender identified in
other words there's a certain
psychological contagion that that
pertains to sexual experimentation and
gender experimentation which is exactly
what you would figure because cliques
have existed in schools for a very long
time any trend any trend that exists in
a public school in any school setting is
going to bring people within that clique
hey how is it that you get kids to dress
like idiot Goths
all you have to do is get a couple of
kids to dress like eighty Agathe and all
the friends dressed like idiot Goths and
the same thing holds true you have a
media that is glorifying Caitlyn Jenner
as woman of the year a group with 50% of
its members becoming transgender
identified represents a rate that is 70
times the expected prevalence for young
adults seventy times according to
Whitman hay is the Brown University
researcher
additionally 62% of parents reported
their teen or young adults had one or
more diagnosis of a psychiatric disorder
or
developmental disability before the
onset of gender dysphoria so in other
words we already know about comorbidity
between depression and gender dysphoria
the idea here is that it's possible that
other mental conditions are translating
themselves over to gender dysphoria
thanks to peers in the group who are
suggesting that this is probably the
solution to whatever difficulty that
you're having in life
48% reported their child's had
experienced a traumatic or stressful
then prior to the onset of gender
dysphoria including being bullied sexual
assaulted or having their parents get
divorced so in other words when you have
troubled kids they are more likely to
experience what this researcher calls
rapid onset gender dysphoria so what did
the left do with this study did they say
okay well let's look at the data maybe
we should drill down maybe we should go
ahead and and do further research on
this maybe we should take a look at the
fact that rates of gender dysphoria are
rapidly multiplying across the West
Australia Great Britain Canada the
United States happening everywhere why
is this happening is it because there's
a sudden biological shift in human
genomes or is it possible that
environmental and social conditions
actually make a difference with regard
to sexual behavior and identification
instead of doing that Brown University
had a different solution a different
solution I'm gonna tell you about that
solution in just one second first you're
gonna have to go over to Daily wire so
daily wire you get $9.99 a month you get
the you get the rest of the show you get
the rest of the under Clavin show you
get the wrist of Michael moles show yet
all of those things for $9.99 a month
you also get the the wonderful mug right
this this year mug right here this
leftist here's hot or cold tumble 499
dollars a year and so the annual
subscription also please go and
subscribe over YouTube or iTunes that
means that you will get our Sunday
special this Sunday we have on a
fantastic guest who I don't know who it
is yet but it will be fantastic because
they're all great we only have on good
guest so go check that out as well we
had largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so the so what did Brown University
do with all of this what did Brown do
with all this
well what Brown did with all of this is
they buried the study it buried the
study and they decided that this study
had to be pulled down so Brown
University couldn't stand the actual
study they caved the university pulled
down a news article about the study
realistically Brown in the journal in
which the original comment was published
plus one turned against the study
because it offended politically correct
sensibilities about transgenderism
around School of Public Health deemed
best Marcus even issued a letter to the
entire community here's what the letter
said quote independent of the
university's removal of the article
because of concerns about research
methodology the School of Public Health
has heard from Brown community members
expressing concerns that the conclusions
of the study could be used to discredit
efforts to support transgendered youth
and invalidate the perspectives of
members of the transgender community
you're reading me here Brown University
a research university hold down one of
its own studies because they said that
it could have hurt people they don't
want to hurt how insane is that okay
basically they're saying that science is
now taking they're openly saying this
right they are saying that science is
taking a backseat that science is taking
a backseat to the realities of political
correctness I'm gonna read that sentence
again because this is insane the school
of public health has heard from the
brown community members expressing
concerns that the conclusions of this
study could be used to discredit efforts
to support transgender youth and
invalidate the perspectives of members
of the transgender community could be
used not is being used is not that is
not the not is used could be used okay
so if the scientific data doesn't back
your preferred political position we're
just gonna pull down the study and then
Brown just assembles they say the
University in school have always
affirmed the importance of academic
freedom and the value of rigorous debate
informed by research
ah-ha-ha-ha-ha the merits of all
research should be debated vigorously
because that is the process by which
knowledge ultimately advances often
through tentative findings that are
often overridden or corrected in
subsequent higher-quality research
this is them saying we really hope this
study isn't true it would be really bad
if this study were true because it might
suggest then not everybody who
identifies as
transgender is suffering from a
biological disorder like gender identity
disorder it's possible that they are
just mistaking their own feelings we
can't say that so let's let's hope that
this study is debunked in the meantime
we'll pull down the study because we're
a bunch of cowards they say the spirit
of free inquiry and scholarly debate is
central to academic excellence at the
same time mm-hmm here it is at the same
time we believe firmly it is uncommon
time public health researchers to listen
to multiple perspectives and to
recognize and articulate the limitations
of their work by the way as I say these
the author of the study specifically
said this is a descriptive study
requiring further research but that
wasn't good enough
Brown pulled it down this process
includes acknowledging and considering
the perspectives of those who criticized
our research methods inclusions and
working to improve future research to
address these limitations and better
serve public health and then I love this
this is the best part there's an added
obligation for vigilance in research
design and analysis anytime there are
implications for the health of the
communities at the center of research
and study so in other words we need to
be rigorous but we need to be SuperDuper
rigorous if we are talking about stuff
the left doesn't like well no that's
actually not the requirement of science
the requirement of science is that you
are supposed to be SuperDuper rigorous
all the way through the requirement of
science is not dependent on whether the
Left likes the result and then you
wonder why folks on the right don't
trust a lot of these scientific results
that seem to be pushed by the left you
know honestly like I think the global
warming is taking place because the data
suggests that global warming is taking
place I accept the reality that a
certain percentage of that global
warming is created by man driven
activities but for folks on the right
who look at the way that the left
punishes people for straying from the
established consensus and sometimes have
left punishes people for straying from a
consensus that is not even
scientifically established that is
politically established do you wonder
why folks on the right don't trust folks
on the left when it comes to their
scientific research that's not an excuse
for people ignoring science and there
are people on right and left who ignore
science about vaccines for example
because it benefits their own position
it creates a confirmation bias but
that's not what this is what we are
watching here is a reverse confirmation
bias you don't like the results of a
study so Brown will pull it down because
it might offend people it's just insane
the commitment of the school to
diversity and
inclusion is central to our mission says
brown we pride ourselves on building a
community that fully recognizes and
affirms the full diversity of gender and
sexual identity and its members these
commitments are an unshakeable part of
our core values as a community so here's
what they're gonna do in an effort to
support robust research and constructive
dialogue on gender identity in
adolescents and youth the school will be
organizing a panel of experts aa panel
of experts we can't actually just
present the study and then have
critiques of the methodology of the
study we will present a panel of experts
namely a bunch of people who agree with
the prevailing politically correct view
of gender identity disorder and then we
will silence everybody else and we will
guess Lisa Lippmann and non tenured
professor fired that's what's gonna
happen to her okay Lisa Lippmann will
never work again at a major research
university that's what's going to happen
to Lisa Lippmann she's gonna go exactly
the same way as Brett Weinstein who is a
biologist over at to a socialist over at
Evergreen University
well Heather Heying who is his wife they
will they will go after anyone it will
go after anyone who does not follow the
basic leftist consensus on politics
it'll destroy science in order to do so
and they will censor people this is cool
this is what creates the anti political
correctness backlash on the on the right
jesse single of new york magazine who is
no right winger he says the honesty here
is noteworthy researchers can publish
findings that support the Born This Way
story line all day long with no problems
anything else will be carefully picked
apart for signs of harmfulness he says
this could be used as justification to
discredit just about any interesting
social science study and that is exactly
right but that is what the left is
dedicated to because the left is
dedicated to one way of thinking and is
the only way of thinking and there will
be no other ways of thinking speaking of
which the left is is also cracking down
on Catholic Charities that's awesome so
it's not just important to screw up kids
when it comes to issues like
transgenderism by failing to acknowledge
there is an environmental component to
how kids feel about their own gender and
sexuality and instead pushing forward
with a leftist social agenda it's now
very it's deeply deeply important that
they shut down Catholic Charities that
are involved in adoption in the way to
split against religious Americans the
Catholic Charities Buffalo were forced
to shut down their adoption and foster
services thanks to state rules that
prohibit any adoption or foster agency
from refusing to send kids to same-sex
partners so I'm
let's say I'm a single mom and I give up
my kid to a Catholic charity because I'm
also Catholic and I'd like my kid to be
raised Catholic the state of New York
says that that Catholic charity cannot
participate in foster care or adoption
services anymore
they have to shut down because the
Catholic charity will not hand the kid
over to a gay couple instead they want
to give preference to stray couples and
not allowed to do that under New York
state law and so Catholic Charities
instead will send those kids presumably
back into the state system so well done
left
well done left we'll make sure that
those kids get stuck in some sort of
foster home as opposed to with straight
parents because we have to make sure
that gay parents are privileged in the
same way that straight parents are even
though a child needs a mother and a
father that's not a religious argument
by the way that is a natural law reason
based argument mommies and daddies are
different anyone who tells you different
is a liar mommies and daddies are
different and if you don't believe me
think about your own mommy and daddy and
ask which one of them you would replace
with a member of the opposite sex and
how much that would change your life to
pretend otherwise his idiotic the same
left that talks about the value of
diversity when it comes to race and
talks about the special value of women
when it comes to feminism and considers
people like stormy D annuals evidence of
feminism says the motherhood is not an
integral component of a child's life
instead two fathers can do the exact
same job as a father and a mother it's
absolute crap and now they will embed it
in law and shut down Catholic Charities
who simply maintain that a child
deserves a mother and a father
so Catholic Charities of a Buffalo is
just the latest this has already
happened in Boston it also happened in
Illinois in 2011 but it doesn't matter
because the left gets what it wants
which is the ability to preside over a
hard left move in all of social areas
Zack Ford who's an ex execrable
human being over at Think Progress
he writes dude get over it you lost
right that's it no the kids lost the
kids lost because these kids might have
been able to get a home through a
Catholic charity be raised in the way
that their parents wanted them to be
raised and instead they're going to be
shunted back into whatever state system
the left wants them shunted into and you
wonder why people are not dumping Trump
the reason why people aren't dumping
Trump is because the left is so insane
because this is the agenda the left is
pushing but the agenda the left is
pushing is stormy Daniels is a here Owen
and stormy Daniels a hero then sex work
is exactly the same as a woman working
as a partner to law firm or that stormy
Daniels is equivalent that talking badly
about stormy Daniels is equivalent to
make
rape victim this is Jill Phillips
inspected the left is suggesting that
scientific research studies be shut down
if they don't reach the proper
conclusions and they're suggesting the
Catholic Charities be shut down because
we have to make sure the kids can be
adopted by gay couples at the same rate
as straight couples because mommies and
daddies are unnecessary you can have two
mommies or two daddies they're exactly
the same thing hey you think that I'm
making you think this is just a case
that I'm exaggerating here here's Nancy
Pelosi they've probably won some
probable future Speaker of the House of
Representatives saying that the the 2018
campaign is going to be about fear we're
gonna have so many women and that's why
the Republicans are so afraid and that's
why President Trump is so afraid he's
afraid of all the women people of color
LGBTQ numbers that will be added to the
ranks in the Democratic Party which is
already a majority of women and people
of color and LGBTQ but it is it's going
to be larger number say the Democratic
coalition is based on this right the
Democratic coalition is not based on
fundamental principles about freedom it
is based on which interest groups can we
cater to and allow dominance in American
politics to dominate other interest
groups in American politics that is what
the left is about though the same left
that will declare Mike Pence a theocrats
is in its in its sole theocratic about
governments itself government is God
they are the they are the great moral
arbiters of the planet and therefore
they get to determine what sort of
science we pursue what sort of adoption
strategies are pursued by religious
people and by people of good faith
around the country they're the ones you
get to determine our social lives and
then they turn around and suggest that
were the fascists and then they wonder
why people are resonating to a populist
rhetoric that says that the left needs
to be stopped then wondering why
conservatives are moving anti left I
don't think there's an excuse for
conservatives to abandon their own
fundamental principles about morality
decency and limited government in order
to slap the left I don't think anti left
is the same thing as conservative but to
ignore the temptation that is being
presented toward moving toward a
populist right-wing anti leftism because
the left has decided that they want to
challenge the the existence of free
thought in American society is for the
left to paint a rather self flattering
picture of exactly how politics in the
United States works at this point okay
time for some things that I like and
then we'll do some things that I hate so
this week I'm doing some Neil Simon
stuff because Neil Simon passed away
over the weekend
Nilsa I'm an incredibly talented writer
this is one of my favorite comedy is
called the goodbye girl I think I've
recommended on the show before but we'll
go back to it as probably two years ago
or three years ago in any case Neil
Simon's goodbye a girl with Richard
Dreyfuss and Marsha Mason Richard
Dreyfuss turns in I think a career best
performance in the goodbye girl he's
really funny the basic plot is that he
the this this woman and her young son
she gets divorced and young daughter
sorry she and she gets divorced and she
needs a roommate basically to stay in
her apartment and Richard Dreyfuss is an
actor and he moves in and it's it's very
funny and very cute and it's it's got
some real moments here here's some of
the trailer say hello to the goodbye
girl
make it fast hi I think there's been
some kind of mistake I sublet this
apartment for this one technically that
apartment belongs to me or do I store in
the place in the morning five minutes
the only practical solution is that we
share the apartment oh you win get your
bags you gets a small bedroom wings
level right
say hello to Richard Dreyfuss say hello
to Marcia Mason and the best part of
this is say hello reduction of Richard
the third and Richard the Richard third
production is hysterically funny because
the director of the production being I
left this suggest that Richard the third
should be played as a homosexual and
Richard the third is lately homosexual
but he also insists that Richard
Dreyfuss play it as openly as possible
and the production is extraordinarily
funny so go check out the goodbye girl
it's well worth the watch it's it's
quite enjoyable okay other things that I
like so finally president Trump came out
and issued a statement about John McCain
that was fitting and useful it only took
him a day and a bunch of pressure he
issued a statement saying despite our
differences on policy and politics I
respect Senator John McCain service to
our country and in his honor had signed
a proclamation to fly the flag of the
United States at half-mast until the day
of his interment which is sort of normal
policy I've asked Vice President Penn's
to offer an address at the ceremony
honoring Senator McCain at the US
Capitol this Friday at the request of
the McCain family I've also authorized
military transportation of Senator
McCain's remains from Arizona to
Washington DC military pallbearers and
band support and a horse and Kayson
during the service at the US Naval
Academy and then he asked also Kelly and
Madison Bolton to represent the
administration at the services this is
what he should have done originally and
then we could avoided this entire silly
controversy but at least Trump got it
right if a little belatedly okay other
things that I like so the president is
cutting a trade deal that he suggests is
really a bilateral trade deal between
the United States and Mexico it is not
it's mostly a revision of NAFTA he wants
to retitle it because Trump enjoys
retitling things he likes rebranding
that's fine the actual trade deal may be
better we have to see the details fully
hashed out it may not be better but
Trump's rhetoric is sort of disconnected
from what's actually going on he's
suggesting that he's scrapping in NAFTA
altogether and renegotiating from
scratch that's not true it's really he's
negotiating changes with Mexico and
Canada and that's basically all that's
happening but if those changes are good
then fine right here's what CNN reports
this is actually true is actually real
CNN reporting there's no formal free
trade deal between the US and Mexico
only an agreement between the two
countries on how to resolve key issues
in their trade relationship as part of
the NAFTA talks but this led the
president to triumphal e state that he
had fixed all of our trade problems by
scrapping NAFTA again that may not be
true but it led to this kind of funny
moment when he called up Enrique Pena
Nieto who's still the president of
Mexico and tried to use a speaker phone
in a moment directly from beep the
president is on the phone
Enrique
yeah you can hook them up hello
you wonder what put that on this phone
rings hello
so yeah solid stuff there from the
President and somebody on his team
probably got a chewing out for for a
little bit of that okay other things
that I like so I have to acknowledge
that I think the bad lip reading folks
are extraordinarily hilarious they're
really really funny and they did a bad
lip reading of Sarah Huckabee Sanders
and members of the media at a White
House press conference will show a
couple of seconds of it's pretty funny
okay idiots are you ready I just can't
stand the faces of you people dead
questioning eyes dummies don't matter
credo what happens when I scratch a
horseradish all over my face now why
would you do this
well I'm definitely gonna scrape it
somewhere yeah you don't matter man G my
beard itches pretty bad is this because
of my bugs
you have literal bugs uh-huh I think
it's mainly bed bugs okay you gotta go
wait no all their videos are really
funny can go check out the bad lip
reading folks did they do a pretty
spectacular job okay time for a couple
of quick things that I hate
all right so begin today with Alyssa
Milano who I don't know why she's
investing herself so much in politics
lately she has every right to do so I
always say that because people take it
when I criticize a celebrity for
speaking they take it as though I'm
criticizing the celebrity for speaking
as opposed to what the celebrity is
saying so Alyssa Milano did this little
video for now this which is just one of
the dumbest sites on the internet now
this they basically make these videos
about fringe folks and then suggest the
mainstream and she did a video about
stopping Brett Kavanaugh who's president
Trump's nominee to the Supreme Court who
will be confirmed and she decided that
she was going to read out suppose it
accounts from supposed victims as though
she was the victim and it got real weird
we have the power to stop Brett
Kavanaugh
I know we do but we have to call our
senators it's not yet a done deal so we
have to bang down their doors and share
our stories because we are all Jane Doe
we are all walking Oliver we are all
Laura Packard and so many more of us are
vulnerable if Brett Kavanaugh is in the
majority on the highest court of the
land oh the crisis mentality oh no we
can't have an originalist on the court
don't do it I just did the level of
drama the Democrats bring to politics
pretty astonishing listen mitt this okay
we're all prone to this one Obama was
president I get overdramatic from time
to time but yeah the the level of panic
about somebody like Brett Kavanaugh is
pretty insipid given the fact that it is
the left that has used the court as a
club against legislators across the
country it is the left that has used the
Constitution as a weapon to wield
against traditional American values over
and over and over again from roe v--
wade to obergefell and the idea that
that Brett Kavanaugh for reading the
Constitution in its properly appointed
judicial role that he's the threat
pretty wild okay other things that I
hate so ESPN is dying in the ratings I
can't imagine why actually I can't
imagine why it's cuz they won't shut up
about politics and just cover sports so
I can't get a damn baseball highlight on
SportsCenter anymore but I can certainly
get half of the ESPN staff yelling at
Tiger Woods an actual black person over
his supposed racism for not ripping
president Trump we get a Max Kellerman
who's as white as I am talking about the
evils of Tiger Woods it really bothers
me
III don't angry at what Tiger Woods said
because it is it is a thoughtless
statement dressed up as a thoughtful
statement and if either holds in
contempt the intelligence of the people
who hear it or else it's just a stupid
thing to say
om saying we have to respect the office
of the president I don't want to get
into politics a stupid thing to say
and Max Kellerman would know because he
is actually the king of stupid things to
say he once was the Duke but he's now
been elevated to actual royalty which is
impressive he was second in line he was
once a prince and then the father of
stupidity died at some point and made
him the king so the king of saying
stupid things Max Kellerman who is just
bad at his job he he thinks Tigard what
is bad but he's not the only one there
was an entire ESPN segment about Tiger
Woods and
Tiger Woods was labeled not really black
which was just excellent first of all we
don't know what Tiger Woods believe he's
Campbell an Asian he's not black when he
got arrested he was black he was listed
as black on the report so let's
understand that Tiger Woods that's the
issue that the african-american
community has always had because
obviously from an historical perspective
you know if one third of you is you it
has a darker hue a dog and a
pigmentation you know the bottom line is
you are black and it is that simple and
you get it even 1/3 I'm just doing up
there um so what so what so Tigers not
black anymore weird because it seemed to
me that the entire media was very
focused on his color when he was winning
majors because it was actually a
breakthrough for black golfers I mean I
was there for that entire time and those
fine does a good thing but now he's not
black anymore because he didn't want to
say anything bad about Trump so Steven
Naismith really sounding off in the most
intelligent possible way
I think the dumbest story of the week
however with regard to sports wasn't
even the Tiger Woods stuff it was the
the Serena Williams bodysuit so she
wanted to wear a cat suit basically at
the French Open and the French Open
banned the cat suit because it was not
in keeping with their fashion
requirements their actual fashion
requirements at these various places
that's why you don't see the players
wearing basically like sweat suits out
there or tracks it anyway Michelle
Beadle says that it is racist to ban
Serena Williams's cat suit because of
the new dress code and so she explains
that the racism racism everywhere race
it doesn't matter by the way that Serena
Williams is by far the most praised
female tennis player of all time and the
best female tennis player of all time
and that the last thing the French Open
wants to do is offend Serena Williams no
must be racism because everybody is a
racist racist everybody racist this is
not a good look for the French Open or
the French and specifically the
gentleman who said you must respect the
game I think there's a I think there's a
racial card being played here because it
is Serena Williams the bootylicious
comment he sounds like the beginning of
the out night God like he's just
offended there's no reason to ban the
outfit because you're right if there are
many other uniforms that show so much
skin and that doesn't seem to be a
problem whatsoever so I think she has
been marked for this and I think the
entire thing is just a bad look for all
of them okay so the the one of the cases
that's being made for this is that you
needed help with her blood clots and
this this helped create circulation
the French generation president the
Tennis Federation president Bernard GOG
Celie he said I think sometimes we've
gone too far he said well no longer be
accepted one must respect the game and
the place well I mean it is a skin tight
bodysuit and let's remember that this is
not the first time that a person has
been banned from wearing a skin-tight
bodysuit at a major hey there's a woman
named Anne white her name might betray
her colour as well a white woman in 1985
she tried to wear a white bodysuit over
to Wimbledon and Wimbledon banned it as
she was wearing a white one-piece lycra
bodysuits racked a lot of attention and
the crowd and the photographer's and
then play was stopped for the day and
Ellen Mills the umpire told her to wear
more appropriate clothing the next day
she did so and she lost the third set
and she said it wasn't kind she know why
I was controversial but like 30 years
ago they were saying that this was an
issue so I guess it's not racist but
it's racist because racism racism and
that's all ESPN cares about I wonder why
nobody wants to watch sports on ESPN oh
maybe it's because I don't even do
sports on ESPN anymore ok we'll be back
here tomorrow with all of the latest I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Sonia Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stevens edited by Alex and Garo
audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah al Vera the Ben
Shapiro show is a daily wire for word
publishing production copyright Ford
publishing 2018